I don't know a centuries-old bell tower
crumbling as a magnitude 7.0 earthquake
strikes the Philippines Northern
provinces it sent people out of their
homes and buildings and into the streets
the Tremor was spelled all the way to
the capital of Manila 300 kilometers to
the South where Metro train operations
were disrupted
of course I was afraid because we didn't
feel that much shaking with previous
Quakes but with this one the impact was
really strong we felt it on the 11th
floor there were items that fell down so
we panicked a bit but we managed to calm
ourselves in severely affected areas
small buildings caved walls crumbled and
historic structures gave in
the earthquake cracked open concrete
roads and triggered landslides
landslides are a problem especially not
only for earthquakes but during rain so
we meet we have to make sure that areas
that are affected by Landslide and
starting or incipient landslides should
be avoided let them do their work
president Ferdinand Marcus Jr opted not
to travel to the region which is where
his hometown is located
but he assured victims of the national
government's continuing efforts to help
them recover from the disaster the
earthquake that struck Northern
Philippines did not generate a tsunami
warning but government Technologies
warned while the worst may be over after
shots are expected to persist for days
finding below Al Jazeera Manila
Richard Gordon is the chairman and chief
executive officer at the Philippine Red
Cross he says the team is actively
responding and supporting relief efforts
across affected areas
just about uh uh 1990 July 16 you had a
very big earthquake in that area in
Baguio uh and a lot of people died there
and now July 27 we have another
earthquake and it affects basically more
or less the same areas except for in
central Busan which is affected uh they
called it the Luzon earthquake so of
course people are more prone to being uh
prepared uh but of course you can never
prepare for a very very strong
earthquake this is one of the stronger
ones of Leeds well right now we're in
the evacuation centers in certain areas
we're doing psychological uh support a
lot of people have been traumatized and
had panicked uh we have provided for
example because of our first aid and
psychological Support also will
distributed face masks and hygiene items
and we'll soon be providing uh blankets
uh and uh mosquito Nets the chickens
mosquito Nets because we have a current
problem of dengue and we are providing
water treatment units as well as tankers
and the rest of the chapters and we have
about 20 chapters around that area are
ready to assist with ambulances we have
four ambulances there in the areas
already and we didn't have to bring
anybody to the hospital so so far I'm
glad that very few people have been
killed relatively and certainly the
casualties uh I haven't gone uh you know
all right but there is a call with the
situation so we have to be careful about
it